the nimmer family shows us a glimpse of
what life is now like for many Lebanese
the basics and Essentials including food
is no longer affordable
a nearly bankrupt State can't provide
services and the poor can't afford to
buy water
ilham doesn't have a refrigerator and
more often than not there's no cooking
gas
foreign
[Music]
most of the days he just brings home
bread
estimated that it costs 30 dollars a
month for a person to eat basic and
essential Foods in Lebanon Bilal earns
forty dollars a month
so
foreign
was the only one who used to get an
education but she's been at home for the
past two years
the World Bank says Lebanon ranks first
in food price inflation that's why faten
tells us buying notebooks and pencils is
not an option
foreign
stories of poverty and despair have
become all too common while minimum wage
has been increased to 90 dollars a month
it is still one-fifth of what it was
before the economic crisis set in
this is the story of one family
nearly a million and the half Lebanese
and more than eight hundred thousand
refugees from neighboring Syria are
struggling to put food on the table
that's more than 40 percent of the
population
Tripoli Northern Lebanon